well it's a big deal and everyone in
washed in and around the country been
waiting for these rules and what we got
from the FAA was a lighter touch than a
lot of people honestly expected they
didn't you didn't need a pilot's license
to fly a drone that was one big fear you
don't need a air worthy certification
for a drone as well that was another
concern that some people had but the
reality is that the rules of their
proposing right now do limit what you
can do with the drone to what you can't
deliver a pizza amazon can't deliver a
box yet because you've got to maintain
the line of sight between the operator
and the drone itself you only fly 100
under 100 miles an hour 500 feet if you
need to maintain the line of sight can't
just walk there well you make a good
point and that's the argument from a lot
of people in the industries like this is
to lawyer you're gonna deliver something
on the beach to someone 200 yards away
well you can't even carry anything under
these rules as well you can't put a load
of payload on there so that's but but
the FAA made clear listen this is the
first step these are proposed rules
we're gonna hear why you think these
need to be expanded why perhaps they've
gone too far and that's what the comment
period that's gonna play out over the
next arguably two years it could be two
years for this finalized Jay what do you
think of the drona sphere well look
here's what's happening in drones and
it's a big deal what we're seeing is a
democratization of 3d space it used to
be you needed a lot of capital and a lot
of technology to be in 3d space now
you're not gonna need anybody can fly a
drone and what you're gonna see is an
enormous category of consumer product
think selfie on steroids is exactly
what's gonna happen selfie this is not
so this is not a commercial issue now
it's not commercial Sumer in it's a
consumer issue and it's a defense issue
because once you've got to draw a bad
cheesy movie of what people thought the
future was going remember every every
camera is about you know a phone now
right think of the video uploads on
youtube if you're not thinking about
this as 3d space for the consumer
population you're missing the whole
story it's not about delivering pizzas
Amazon's gonna make a lot of money
selling millions of drums so if the FAA
just getting it wrong or I think the eff
is looking in a commercial environment
because the FAA is it used to be the
princess turbines like Congress you've
got to look at this as an as an
opportunity for a business sector where
they do think the faa estimates could be
a hundred million dollar industry
quickly in terms
commercial drone usage they point to
aspects where you could save lives all
those people who climb the towers the
the cellular towers and the TV towers 95
people have died in the last like 10
years hallanders wrong replace those
people because you can send a drone up
to integral shower we have any sent a
person's roads are gonna be a five to
ten billion dollar industry not 100
million dollar business is gonna be a
consumer business it's like oculus rift
these guys are ahead the government's
regulating yesterday's way of thinking
and I can appreciate the FAA thinks
about jet liners we're talking about
hobbyists like biohackers yeah and when
you want to worry about a drone it's not
the missile you going to attach the
drone that you got to worry about it's
the bioterrorism you're gonna attach to
a so if you're right I don't know what
that means it means i can put an agent a
nerve agent and a little bit of it i can
infect you with a pathogen anthrax a
disease smallpox and i can fly a drone
as long as i'm 17 years old the FAA says
I can fly it the most powerful
pound-for-pound asymmetric weapon in the
world is bioterrorism weapons not
explosive weapons groans can lift that
Stephanie that's why they were so worked
up and washed it when I'm so worked up
right now roan landed in the front yard
of the White House that's the kind of
concern that work that's what they were
ever it's not an explosive you're
looking in the wrong sense of them it's
about power pound-for-pound bioterrorism
agents can be lifted by drones however
for consumers I just want a small camera
I want a wedding I want to be followed
around I want my friends and I I want to
be and I'm gonna having fun party right
now member the software on these drones
can avoid other drones can fly inside
spaces think of what happened in
Hollywood when the boom allowed the
camera to come off the ground the whole
schatzker family skiing down the slope
was their drill nestle aren't you scared
I mean if NSA employees it can it can
get their hand what are open college
kids welcome to the new world is that
that's the world we live in college kids
are doing you're ok with that ok not ok
you don't have a choice we don't put the
technology genie back in the bottle
that's not how it works it's weird you
know we're waiting FAA says no the FAA
what will we do with the FAS Oh remember
the air these are a walk
oh my that's for good mercial uses this
doesn't affect the hobbyist types the
teenagers the college kids around their
separate rules for them you know and
they'll be following those rules they
won't be going all those but oh yeah
they'll be checking in case you know
what college kids oh yeah on to a voyeur
ISM that's not a powerful force no
voyeurism on kid never